for a season finale it feels like a
season finale
why my game plan is to have some fun and
hopefully do better than katie i feel
bad for jess
oh my god open the door open the door
cut cut cut
hi i'm mimo and i'm kelly we are back
with another episode of lost in
translation and i cannot miss an
opportunity to mess with my friends
today we're having katie and jasmine go
head to head with no help from each
other to see how each of them translate
the same recipe maybe separating them
this time will be a good idea since it
didn't go well last time probably
oh we made something that's so different
if this is your first time joining us we
put a recipe through google translate we
go from english to urdu to thai kamai
and many many more times and then back
to english to get a hilariously
translated recipe let's go mess with our
friends do it
[Music]
back from vacation and ready to torture
me i am so ready ready
uh no we just ran away
taste of the stomach stomach
it sounds delicious that doesn't sound
that great let's do it let's begin step
number one connect and crush one yellow
evil
one yellow evil connect and crunch right
now i'm thinking one yellow evil could
be one yellow onion right off the bat
i'm like seeing bananas here
i'm seeing squash or a yellow squash
is there anything in the freezer
there's sartino's pizza rolls this is a
nightmare of yellow
i'm gonna do some word association no i
don't i'm not good at word association
jasmine's so good she's like eat water
strawberry shrubbery cold chill chill
spoon iced metal like she's just squash
press press
smash
smash
kill kill evil i'm gonna use one of my
hints at the very top because i feel
like this is so important evil things
make you cry
onions
onions onions i wasn't even thinking i
don't think jazz is gonna use her clue
on step one i think it's onion i think
connect and crush is peel and dice or
chop let's just hope i'm making the
right decision here my game plan is to
have some fun she has more confidence
you know she's been doing this and
hopefully do better than katie but if
not it's okay whatever step two squeeze
one pound squash
eat well and cut well leave me alone
you've got squash squash could be
potatoes
i think i'm gonna do
potatoes i'm committing i'm a little sad
that katie's not here to bully me too
leave me alone
i'm gonna do potatoes i'm gonna do yukon
golds because i like them i thought
about the fingerling but they're kind of
harder to peel and i think i'm going to
need to peel if i'm going to be
squeezing
though i do like skin
but which potato to do
i'm going to go with russet
potatoes are nice and rinsed and now i'm
going to peel them leave me alone means
set to the side
i think squeezing is is
hash browns like i feel like we're
making a fritter which
i don't know i'm just gonna quickly keep
peeling these and then we'll go to
shredding them i'm going to squeeze one
pound squash and i hope that squash is
not actually squashed gorgeous gorgeous
step three put two cups chestnut water
in a hot pan until softened you reduced
the temperature i did nothing of the
stars
not water i think that's like telling me
to put something in a hot pan bring it
up to a boil and then reduce to a simmer
what it is i have no idea there's so
many oils over here i don't want to look
okay um
maybe i should use him i'd like to use a
hint water doesn't mix well with
oil
chestnut water is canola oil
are these chestnut waters they're full
of water and they're like little nuts on
the vines
peanut oil
nice let's do that i think that these
are
chestnut waters and i am going to
measure out two cups i actually love to
make like a quick tomato jam have you
anyone do that
i'm gonna pretend i'm making tomato jam
right now oh i feel like there's no oil
or anything in here but it doesn't say
like put two cups water in a hot pan
it doesn't say anything about oil
now i'm adding two cups of chestnut
water into my pot which is peanut oil at
least i think it is step number four add
oil in the pizza five to seven minutes
until salty and
wait but i've softened something and now
something's becoming salty and soft
no is that the pizza
wow wow wow wow add oil in the pizza
maybe my pizza is potato dude pizza
rolls
this is a good day i'm having a nervous
break
i feel like onions could go in here for
five to seven minutes i'm gonna add the
onions in i'm gonna let that go for five
to seven minutes until they're salty and
soft i think salty and soft is soft and
brown
my onions look salty and soft so i am
just going to remove them and put them
onto this paper towel here i think my
sauce here is the pizza so i'm going to
add some oil and then i'm going to add
some salt because it says let it get
salty and soft i'm going to mix all my
tomatoes together this is not right
but it's very much like how i make a
quick tomato jam
go back to the tomato
i'm committed to these tomatoes and
we're gonna move forward and i'm happy
about it
step number five fruit should not be
eaten and stored while using fat
you guys are so mean even katie's not
this mean
this is the fruit
because the tomato is a fruit and they
are like little nuts and i think that
you i'm gonna set this aside and i don't
think it wants me to eat it yet don't
eat it yet
i'm gonna reduce it i'm gonna set off to
the side that's kind of a very pretty
color
set the onions to the side for now also
leave the oil because we might need some
onion oil i guess
so i'm just going to set that to the
side for now step number six cut the six
whites into cubes add some isotopes
was i this made to you i feel like this
steps easy yeah six whites six egg
whites into cubes sick cut cut
cut the three
isotopes what are isotopes is that to do
with salt or crystallization
cut the
three cut the potatoes
into six cubes and
salt them i will cut my potatoes into
six cubes i'm gonna add some isotopes i
just feel like something's missing so
i'm gonna use my last hint what comes
first the chicken or the egg i am just
going to crack six eggs into this bowl
i'm gonna look in the fridge there's
pepperoni it's tofu there's eggs crack
crack six white eggs put six eggs in a
bowl and add some salt common's almost a
thousand
step number seven tuck in sweet potatoes
and onions and wait five minutes
i think
oh i've got onions i've got sweet
potatoes tuck them in
put them together i'm gonna have to cut
these into smaller pieces
and then combine everything with the
eggs i don't understand why i need to
wait five minutes to fold everything
into the eggs but
sure i'm gonna put my potatoes in my
eggs i have so much fear because there's
just really no turning back so many
onions like i don't know if i want that
many onions in this dish now i'm gonna
add in my chopped potatoes my onions i
am so curious as to where katie is in
this step she's probably screaming
why
next step place three tablespoons of
canned butter on a large plate can
jar
butter
oil
jarred oil
i think that's heat up three tablespoons
of butter on a hot plate it could
definitely be butter ghee ghee
kabigi i saw a ghee over there so it
could be ghee instead of butter on a
large plate
on a pan canned butter
i like butter
ghee is good i think i'm gonna do
cookies i think canned butter is
clarified butter aka ghee and my large
plate is my large pan while that's
heating up i'm going to move on to the
next step all right next step step
number nine animals sizzle for one
minute three to five
is it my potato mixture
i think this is our animal
or is it animal meat oh no i think this
is all a ruse should i use my hand
yeah i guess i'll use my head you were
on the right path when you thought egg
was animal so this was a terrible time
to use
right oh sizzle like high for a minute
and then reduce it for three to five
my gut
tells me it's this all right i'm gonna
add this in there i'm gonna let that sit
for three to five i'm gonna add my
animal it's a little sizzle this is
beautiful except for my chunky
so i'm gonna let this sizzle for one
minute on high and then i'm gonna reduce
the heat and let it cook for about three
to five minutes i am seeing some of the
egg cook along the edges i feel like i
can move on to the next step can i read
the next step step 10 cover cover cover
cover
and fill with good bread cover cover
cover cover okay okay okay
cover
cover this there's bread crumbs
good bread bread crumbs okay what i
don't see is a top big enough to cover
this
none of them are big enough which means
they never anticipated me covering it i
mean i can cover it maybe i use the
wrong pan maybe cover is like flip it
flip it flip it flip it flip it fill
with
good steam
let it steam up
yes that's what i'm gonna do i do have
tomatoes so i could like cover it with
the tomatoes i'm in a cover cover with
my tomato jam i think filled with good
bread is flip it so here we go oh my god
oh my god open the door open the door
cut
everything's all right the building
didn't catch on fire that was an epic
flip i'm gonna put this back in this is
a mess oh no
my tomatoes step 11. put the turtle in a
deep bowl and cook for three to five
minutes what like a deep dish pie dish
i'm gonna let it cook on this side for
three to five minutes and i'm not gonna
overthink it my gut says to finish
cooking this and then transfer it into
this pie dish and then broil for three
to five minutes it's perfect
you can't tell me that's wrong
step number 12 click on the small line
to complete the egg as the water rises
so does the space that makes absolutely
no sense is it like a haiku
my egg is complete i think i might need
to skip that step i think it's like take
your spatula go around and make sure
it's not sticking the water is rising
it's rising off the pan i feel like i
already did this so i'm going to move on
to the next step step number 13 retire
alaska from the oven i think that means
removed from the pan onto a plate oh my
god all my eggs
that's going to be a garnish for this
i can't wait to see what jasmine made
i'm pretty sure that meant to remove
this from the oven which i've already
done so i'm going to move on to the last
and final step last step step number 14
stop for about 10 minutes before pruning
i'm gonna assume that's like let it rest
for gemini's like let it cool for 10
minutes before you eat this so i'm gonna
let this rest for 10 minutes before
enjoying i can't wait to see what
jasmine does i'm not excited to show her
what i did
let's bring them in let's do it
katie
billy and me are tough they are helpful
yeah all right bring them in
and yet so different
you added tomatoes okay we're ready for
the real one
three two one
oh
so what is this dish called it is called
tortilla espanola and it's from spain
wow it's a spanish omelet with onions
and potatoes let's try yours first okay
and then we'll try mine and then the
real thing sounds good cheers
i love the tomatoes
i don't need another bite of mine you
know i make a tomato jam i was telling
oh my god
cheers
it's good
it's not
it's better than mine cheers
[Laughter]
the thinly sliced onion and the
seasoning this is much better honestly
though i don't feel like we were too off
no not at all this was the hardest
recipe we've ever gotten what a fun way
to end the season i love you
love you
thank you guys so much for watching this
was so much fun so much fun thanks so
much for your love and support and we
will see you next time bye
[Music]
[Applause]
wore an yay
my shirt was see-through
look how oily my paper is by the way can
you see that
lip made me cry i always feel like
jasmine's like i need to get a bigger
bowl i feel like i could have gone with
the smaller pot why am i blinking crazy
crazy crazy
have you seen that tick tock
crazy
no i haven't really got
let me tell you a little bit more
[Music]
you